was würden sie dann bestellen machen sie
einfach irgendwas okay also wir nehmen
das
ich kann jetzt schon sagen jetzt gibt es
glaube ich ärger mich gibt es kein geld
[Musik]
geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut
leute ich muss wirklich sagen ich habe
mich die letzten tage so gesund ernähren
also es war wirklich richtig gesund ich
habe jeden tag salat gegessen
jeden tag zwei bananen ich glaube ich
habe ich in der letzten woche nur einmal
ungesund oder was heißt union gewesen
ich habe eine pizza gegessen naja ist
auch egal
das habe ich mir nämlich alles für das
heutige video aufgespart ich weiß nur
wie letzte woche mein video gesehen habt
die person vor mir entscheidet was ich
erste also ich bin halt durch
verschiedene drive ins gefahren und hab
halt immer das bestellt oder hab gesagt
jo gibt man einmal das was gibt man
einmal das wird ein bisschen an sich auf
jeden fall habe ich gesagt hallo
das hört sich ein bisschen komisch an
ich hätte gern einmal genau das was der
vor mir hatte geht das sollte das doch
nicht gesehen habt das auf jeden fall ab
und eines kann ich euch sagen nicht
warum kommt ein heftiges video und zwar
werde es noch beim friseur machen also
wirklich besser denn der von mir hat
sich eine klasse schneiden lassen
dann mache ich vielleicht auch nicht ja
wir werden sehen ich will eigentlich gar
nicht lange lagern wir haben jetzt
samstag und ich würde sagen ab ins auto
ach ich hab euch noch gar nicht erzählt
dass wir machen kein problem mache ich
im auto
ich glaube das ist eine gute kamera
position oder sollte ich habe jetzt
endlich mal geschafft meine kamera hier
am auto anzubringen das ist ja ganz
wichtig letztes mal hat mir nämlich das
problem da hatten wir diese dumme
klimaanlage so richtig rein gepustet und
meine kleine kamera die kann das nicht
verarbeiten und ich habe heute auch
leider kein mikrofon schutz dafür
deswegen ist es gut dass jetzt da oben
steht also ich erkläre ich das ganze
sehr gerne mal eben kurz noch in der
garage und zwar machen wir heute
folgendes ja jetzt gut zu hören
letzte woche ging es darum dass der für
uns entschieden hat
es ist ein richtiges dorf die person vor
mir hat entschieden was es für mich zu
essen gibt diesmal machen wir es anders
und der mitarbeiter also die person die
meine bestellung aufnimmt sei es jetzt
irgendwie im drive seinem restaurant was
auch immer entscheidet dass ich weiß
noch nicht wie ich das genau machen
man könnte natürlich sagen ja ich hätte
gern einmal das was du am liebsten isst
man könnte auch sagen ich hätte gerne
einmal irgendwas man könnte auch sagen
ich hätte gerne einmal das was
deine oma am liebsten ist so also ja das
ist vielleicht ein bisschen komisch naja
ich bin gespannt und das wäre bestimmt
wieder ganz unterhaltsam
deswegen will ich euch viel spaß bei dem
video last auf jeden fall jetzt schon
mal daumen nach oben
für weitere partie und auch wenn ihr auf
die friseur sache bock habt leute man
kann wirklich sagen das wetter heute ist
richtiges aprilwetter wahrscheinlich die
sonne war regen das extrem war gewittert
es dann scheint wieder die sonne auf
jeden fall habe ich mir als erstes ziel
für heute ich habe im letzten video
gesagt ich war schon extrem lange nicht
mehr
wir haben uns cave sie rausgesucht
einfach mal schnell durchfahren ohne
probleme klappt dort das lieblingsessen
von mitarbeitern zu erstellen oder was
auch immer also ich melde mich wenn ich
da bin und bis dahin wünsche ich euch so
leute ich bin angekommen
jetzt schauen wir mal was ganz schön
eigentlich eine
ob es klappt ich muss so kurz gucken
hallo ich war schon ewig nicht mehr hier
wäre das möglich dass sie mir einfach
irgendwie das geben was sie nehmen
würden geht das können sie meist auch
das geben was sie am besten für mich
eigentlich beides für eine person so ok
danke leute das war ein sehr gutes
gespräch
ich habe überhaupt keinen plan wie teuer
das jetzt wird danke
habe ich jetzt überhaupt bezahlt ich
habe gar nichts bezahlt fast immer leute
er hat ja auch nicht so soll ich wieder
zurückfahren dach kommen egal
ich mache werbung für kfc ich musste
jetzt irgendwie nichts zahlen
und ich habe noch das bekommen was
irgendwie empfohlen habe was auch immer
das ist ich muss nicht mal reingucken
die hat irgendwas von der combo gesagt
ja so ist ja verrückt
sollte das ist ja ein geiler anfang vom
video ohne spaß ich hab nichts bezahlt
ich habe ja am anfang oft gefragt leute
was glaubt ihr wie teuer wird das dann
habe ich erst das getränk bekommt heute
das ist mir noch nie passiert dass ich
das nie vergessen haben das geld zu
nehmen
daher komme ich da bin na ja wir fahren
jetzt erst mal zurück das ist aus ich
habe super ich habe nicht nur eine tüte
geschafft zwei füßen bekommen und großes
getränken also das hat locker über zehn
euro gekostet leute schreib ihm doch
bitte in die kommentare
ob euch das schon mal passiert ist keine
ahnung vielleicht bin ich über 18 seid
dass hier im drive nicht zahlen musste
oder was heißt über 18 sagen wir einfach
bock einfach nicht zahlen muss sind weil
die kassiererin das vergessen hat oder
der kann sichere weil das kann ja sein
sogar ich habe keine ahnung weil ich
habe nochmal gut nachgedacht und ich bin
mittlerweile sicher ich habe mich zu
zahlt man ihn gekommen ich hatte zehn
euro drin hier wie immer dürfen trotzdem
habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt was ich
denn jetzt überhaupt habe okay also
getränk haben wir ne cola das ist ja
auch schon mal das hat er gesagt
und hier drin sind auf jeden fall einmal
pommes und so eine checkbox ich denke
mal genau hier sind schicken drin
jetzt kriege ich auch den kommoden wir
haben wir nämlich so eine mischung aus
allen verschiedenen schicken die die
dort haben also zumindest wie die dann
paniert sind und gewürzt und so glaube
ich was ich mich dann jetzt aber frage
ist was ist dann ihr drin weil das ist
ja ein typisches menü
ach so leute den salat den hatte ich
noch in erinnerungen feiere ich nämlich
richtig aber irgendwie so eine soße er
das ketscher bis dabei also leute das
war jetzt schon mal
wir sehen uns zu hause wieder haben
jetzt auch endlich richtig hunger leute
ich gucke gerade ein bisschen youtube
und esse dabei eine soße war irgendwie
nicht dabei deswegen habe ich selber
ketchup jetzt hier manchmal kurz zeigen
wollte und zwar habe ich noch einen
youtube-kanal das ist hier der alex w
kleiner witz also der heißt wirklich so
da kommen jeden tag drei videos ich habe
euch den mal ganz oben in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und ich werde euch
super dankbar so fühle mich eigentlich
für mich leute ich wäre euch super
dankbar wenn ihr einfach mal auf den
link klickt kurz den kanal abonniert ich
werde jetzt gleich auf jeden fall mal in
meiner instagram story posten oder so
passt ihr lieblingsessen ist und wo wir
es nicht hinfahren soll
vielleicht gibt's ja noch irgendwas was
ich so noch gar nicht kennen anstatt
jetzt halt wieder beim nächsten
ungesunden laden zu landen sonst gehen
wir einfach heute abend mal was richtig
gesundes essen ein paar sekunden später
was geht ab mega spontane aktion
ich bereite mich jetzt eigentlich wollte
ich wirklich hier bleiben weil ich heute
morgen dann spart auch noch dieses
videos aufnehmen und so ich weiß
allerdings nur um 10 10 uhr nach
frankfurt die lobbys besucher schon ewig
nicht mehr deswegen würde ich sagen ja
der druck geht weiter ich hoffe ich
kriege das entspannt und vernünftig mit
den hin
falls nicht kann das video leider nicht
morgen dann das soll morgen online wir
fahren jetzt allerdings erstmal los weil
ich muss mich wirklich habe auch keinen
bock irgendwie als um 12 uhr daran zu
kommen obwohl es wahrscheinlich
schwierig wird ernst zu kommen deswegen
würde ich sagen licht aus gar nicht dann
aber an uns glauben
das ist wirklich so spontan jetzt aber
man sagt hier mal die spontanen aktionen
sind die besten
deswegen machen wir das sie kann ich
finde ich auch gut also leute was geht
einem würden wir zur nächsten tag
woanders auch dabei sind ja den habe ich
jetzt überreden können mitkommen wir was
nicht hab voll bock darauf gab so aus
wie sich überwiegend auf jeden fall
fahren wir jetzt zusammen zu mcdonalds
und ich hab dir schon erklärt worum es
geht wir mit ein
und da wir sagen zu dem der da arbeitet
irgendwie so dass der halt darüber
entscheidet was wir dann habe ich sagen
einfach mal junge hat speck tiere und
dann sagt er hier schmeckt ist
hoffentlich oder sagen wir okay jsl jkr
ich kann mich nicht entscheiden kommt zu
mir immer zu empfehlen da sagte ja und
das menü
ich will wissen was wenn du es an
unserer stelle wären sonst zu bestellen
wenn du jetzt bist du bestellen sagt es
ist okay und ich bin mal gespannt ob wir
heute was bezahlen müssen weil ich hab
mir schon erzählt gestern musste
nichts pizza kastens war schon lustig
diese wgs ins auto und fahren und mal
los das gleich was geht
ok du musst mir jetzt den weg sagen wir
machen erstmal pause hier leute wir sind
angekommen jetzt bin ich mal geschafft
ich habe aber sicher die hand läuft oder
kurzen moment noch mitte ich bin jetzt
schon sagen also die richtig genervt
sich an gott oder entschuldigung
wir können sich so ganz entscheidend
ehrlich gesagt kurze frage können sie
uns einfach irgendwas zusammenstellen
was wir dann nehmen
was würden sie ihm jetzt bestellen
was würden sie dann bestellen machen sie
einfach irgendwas okay also wir nehmen
das
ich kann jetzt schon sagen jetzt gibt es
glaube ich ärger ich glaube es gibt 19
die wird auch die kamera sehen diese
richtung sind wir hier richtig weil sie
vorne ja so zwei sachen zusammen
schwierige aufgabe ist das eine
schwierige aufgabe
okay aber danke schön dass das klappt
und wir haben wir freunde sehen bekommt
sie weiter wissen dass sie immer mit
meiner aktion bitteschön
der rest ist für sie
wieso nicht okay dann alles alleine
machen das an die kinderhilfe hey warum
das countryfest auch nicht vor allem sie
hat ihr einfach sagen können
danke oder bin so gespannt ich habe auch
heute richtig hunger ja
wir machen mit so anderen leuten so eine
challenge ist für sein video und wir
müssen jeder so sachen bestellen und
dann so vergleichen wer die besseren
nerven hat man wirklich auch andere
mittel einsetzen sonst sagen
naja
20 58 franken
aha danke danke danke schön
also was man ja schon mal sehen kann ist
es ist ein etwas mut
heute wie sie jetzt auf dem parkplatz
und what is in the box was er macht ganz
noch auf ganzen müsst ihr ihn trotzdem
sehen
okay wir schauen jetzt mal was ihr
angetan hat das immer abwechseln wir
dabei aber trotzdem okay ich wieder
gespannt
das hier ist als nächstes hat sie uns
rein getan jetzt natürlich hier wenn die
bürger besser wenn sich dort genau kann
man das wird einfach mal da steht
doppelt immer dann brauche ich glaube
dass nur die verpackung
aber eigentlich haben wir der nicht
herauskommt
ich kenne den pass ist mein lieblingsjob
agassa das ist sogar genau der bürger ja
ein bisschen zugesagt jetzt ja du kannst
du einbringen haben ich wollte die
bürger dann kann ich von dem blogger so
ein bisschen haben aber was das jetzt
auch so gesagt irgendwie noch was
mischung aus wasser bestehen haben so
ganz so viel dreck gezogen hast du dich
sicher war dass man gleichzeitig
reinbeißen weil ich glaube ich habe auch
vorher noch nie so waren so was gegessen
also so eine partie war ganz okay ich
bin sowieso hat sich so oft ich bin nur
für videos immer bei solchen sachen
boracay reinbeißen in der burger von der
anderen seite einmal abreißen
von der ganz andere von einer ganz
anderen seite weil schmeckt so hoffe ich
weg auch so wie ich mir vorgestellt hab'
ja so ein bisschen nach so ein bisschen
arbeit das ist bin ich immer mehr
richtig guter ausdruck dass ich weg nach
weit jetzt er ohne schwarze wenn man
sowas vegetarisches ist kann ich immer
noch schlecht als das erinnert mich an
wald wurde das jetzt negativ zu meinen
leute ich will euch jetzt auch gar nicht
gehen mit unserem essen nerven schreibt
trotzdem aber weitere ideen was man noch
machen kann gegen die kommentare weil
roman hat mich schon gesagt das war ist
eine witzige idee ich hatte die idee
megageil wir brauchten moderation oder
die leute was geht ab ich bin schon
wieder zu hause ich habe noch ein paar
reaktions videos aufgenommen für meinen
zweiten kanal also abonniert auf jeden
fall und schaut euch die an würde mich
sehr freuen
ansonsten ist mir aufgefallen dass ich
das jetzt nicht 24 stunden komplett
durchgezogen habe es hat einfach nicht
geklappt ich habe es zeitlich nicht
geschafft das video ist jetzt trotzdem
schon so lang natürlich könnte es sein
dass noch irgendwas lustiges passiert
wenn ich das jetzt noch mal mache ich
finde dann wird es allerdings zu lange
ich hoffe das versteht ihr und man kann
ja weiterhin kohle challenges machen
also schreibt mir gerne ideen in die
kommentare
es hat echt eine menge spaß gemacht wie
es werde ich angerufen und würde schnell
sagen daumen nach oben abonnieren und
wir sehen uns morgen und übermorgen
wieder gibt es ein neues video haut rein
[Musik]